ça va pas trop bien il parle je sais que
physiquement je le la fin et que le fait
que je perde du poids fait que je suis
moins performant c'est obligé la tête
qui tente bah oui je peux mettre un
pitbull ne sont pas tous des piétons
non
je sais que chez mon corps me lâche et
après midi je me suis levé j'ai failli
tomber serrano qui m'a retenu claouey ça
commence vraiment vos moyens
[Applaudissements]
thomas tu étais pas bien quand même
non j'étais mon corps et me lâchait
ouais j'avais perdu 12 13 kg le stress
qu'il aura 12 13 kg comment tu te sens
tu te sentais que tu vois que tu pouvais
plus tenir
moi je mettais un pied devant l'autre
dès que je me dis que je me mettais
debout je tournais la tête elle tourner
sa une au même endroit pour ta santé ou
pas non j'avais pas peur puisque on a un
très bon suivi il ya le nayrac ainsi on
a besoin à le médecin qu'est ce qu'il
disait médecin bas me disais que ça
allait franchement y'a que quand je me
mettais deux bouts en fait la tête elle
tournée mais après ça a l'air savais tu
comment tu fais pour faire des épreuves
et tout mais sur les épreuves en fait je
devais avoir l'adrénaline où la
compétition tout ça ça me falloir une
erreur été traités et c'est pas pour ça
qu'il était toujours énervé parce que
tout se décide à vis des petits coups de
colère quand même dans koh lanta non
mais après c'est mon tempérament assez
sa tête eut peut alors pas c'est pas
faux comptes afin n'ont souvent jamais
alors quand les aventuriers avaient
éliminé tehani tu n'avais d'ailleurs
qu'un mot à la bouche
vengeance regardez de plus moi je
discute avec personne
tu vois pas ce que les gens ne
m'intéresse pas quand même plus loin là
il y en a 3 tu peux même plus me voir en
peinture
laetitia lucie et des vincent je veux
même pas qu'il m'adresse la parole n'est
pas un bon jour dans les futures des
non-passagers trouve malheur c'est que
j'ai soif de revanche
si je peux te faire un coup d'état ça me
ferait plaisir
je vais manger ce qui s'est passé je
voulais marange ans et ils savent que si
je gagnais bas mon vote ira directement
à eux non plus ce tirage au sort
tu es bien fait les choses que tu es
avec vincent tiercé gagnant comme ça
est-ce que l'aventuré dangereuses non la
voiture avait pas dangereuse
non vraiment tu t'es jamais senti en
danger de jamais gerland et un médecin
quand on a besoin tout ce qu'il faut
avant de partir on fait les examens
qu'il faut ouais donc on est très bien
suivi c'est ça les psys tout non non
franchement à l'aventuré indépendant
gilles vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec non
c'est rory c'est pour ça que denis
brogniart a redonné du riz de rio
candidats danse était déjà de l'arrière
parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien et pourtant
il avait pris des candidats aux profils
de sportif mais il a beaucoup plu il
avait même réduit la saison 35 jours au
lieu de 40
mais les candidats sont trop faibles et
pour moi ça devient riche soir-là cette
séquence qui va faire beaucoup parler
regarder
j'en peux plus
inquiets des projets sa voix me prends
sur moi comme j'ai jamais pris autant de
même les petits poissons rouges bon tout
d'annuaire ces malades balle europa il
était plus qu'aucun plus dérangeant
c'était sale et de ouf donc voilà voulu
prendre les choses en main
d'ici là on va boire toute la mer est
les petits poissons toute la nuit ça va
faire des histoires sont éliminés parce
qu'ils sont fait c'est pour ça que vous
semblez alambo dj vous dit j'ai pas
demandé c'était pas mes informations
mais ça c'est bien volontiers s'étaient
cicatrisées
non non non mais si tu disais ça rit ça
mais je sais que ça sert à reese et très
franchement très franchement je n'arrive
pas que ça je vous le dit les yeux dans
les yeux
pour moi vous êtes senti faible et vous
avez tout fait pour sortir imbécile je
vous dise droit dans les yeux mais j'ai
pas demandé à sortir mais connaissant
bien bas déjà on voit je suis un jeune
tu le dernier des quatre jaunes donc là
j'étais une tête à abattre donc après
j'ai eu la chance d'être un destin lié
avec maxime donc ça m'a permis de passer
encore un conseil et là on voit je fais
un malaise juste quelques heures avant
le conseil oui donc en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que ils vont pas me garder
moi qui est un handicap dans ce cas et
c'est donc bien sûr qu'ils votent pour
moi j'aurais fait la même chose
est-ce que c'est trop dangereux
guillaume ou non ces patrons comme je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec gilles on
reproche souvent aux émissions ne pas
tenir lors c'est samantha c'est quoi
c'est d'envoyer les aventuriers en
survie 35 jours sur une île ce genre de
séquences à d'être très dur pour vous
d'avoir la tête qui tournait ça
crédibilise démission vous voulez quoi
j'aime qu'on leur donne à manger quand
ils ont un peu faim nous faisons un peu
plus facile à intervilles
oui c'est le but d'un rayon de koh lanta
désolé mais la raison des combats ça
veut dire que rien est truqué c'est à
dire vous mangez pas y'a rien truqués
nous on avait pas le feu pendant deux
jours on n'a pas eu de feu on n'a pas
mangé rien quand il n'aime pas un gars
qui vous dit y chercher à fabriquer des
gars qui passe briquet bonjour acheter
un briquet personnes imaginez il sait
mieux que les aventures guest que les
aventuriers ou as tu sais qu'il s'agit
et a dit voilà ce que j'ai vécu c'est
mon histoire
et visiblement il est connu pour ceux
qui ont regardé l'émission pour dire ce
qu'ils pensent
tu penses bien que s'il avait envie de
dire autre chose il le dire ils signent
des contrats où ils n'ont rien
signé un contrat vous n'avez pas le
droit de dire ce qui se passerait si je
suis né en outre on s'est parlé de neuf
morts
vous pouvez pas dire ce qui se passe là
bas moi j'ai vécu ce qui se passe là bas
vous êtes restés ici ouais mais pas dire
ouais moi je peux pas dire ce qui se
passe sur le plateau à moi je vais te le
dire parce qu'ils sont franchement je
vais te dire c'est c'est plus dur ici
que koh lanta pour moi oui question
voyez bonsoir j'ai une question est ce
que en vous renvoyant après coup vous
vous êtes dit il ya quand même des
moments où j'ai été un peu tête de con
mais c'est une bonne question mais c'est
une bonne question me la posent souvent
a battu voix près non je suis quelqu'un
d'entier c'est à dire que quand gm gm à
2000% c'est à dire que quand on à gg
j'ai aimé mathieu myriam chanif quand on
était tous les quatre on était
intouchable donc bien sûr que de les
aimer très fort et quand on les a
éliminés un par un bas petit à petit bas
je voulais me venger je voulais les
venger donc j'ai tout repris d'un coup
et c'est pour ça après non je suis
quelqu'un qui aime bien taquiner c'est
pour ça aussi je taquine wojtek l'or
alors regarder parce que la mairesse ans
a fait botter propriété omar gaieté et
c'est vrai que voilà il a des potes
shiny programme huawei logement si on
fait une embarcation comme on fait une
cabane en bois
alors parmi nous je pense qu'un par
aurélien on va faire que des sous marins
ap les leviers pour air tahiti
j'ai fait la précommande quand on lit ar
tahiti et basses et que
on a déjà pris son billet maintenant
ailleurs expliqué adam et moi sommes
venus avec 30 g de rien bon on va dire
c'est mieux que rien et là il ya une
tête puisque les autres ne revient pas
c'est hervé vient pas du tout sa tête de
loin ou de près c'est toujours la même
je vote magali tu sors de taliance je te
souhaite rapprocher hockey comme ça
c'est maintenant que les rouges au
monsieur la girouette et ben ils sont en
supériorité numérique donc je vais
bientôt potard besançon la prochaine
question est-ce que c'était pas bien de
vous garder aussi stratégiquement pour
garder quelqu'un de faible
enfin sk s'adonnent les de l'émission on
regarde pas les gens aiment justement
pour les avoir en finale équipes r&d et
gagner ouais peut-être c'est vrai mais
après on a vu que le dernier conseil ils
ont donné un kilo de riz de neil a donné
un kilo de riz donc peut-être que je
leur faisais peur moi c'est ça que je
reproche à l'émission s'est donné un
kilo de riz sans gagner aussi pourquoi
même si on l'a gagné parce qu'ils
expliquent qu'ils ont là bien géré on a
bien géré les rations oui
donc c'est pour ça que tu nous le donne
donc alors tu as été éliminé vendredi
soir était dégoûté couac a été éliminé
au point brasse
ouais je suis déporté on est toujours
des goûters si près du but ce que nombre
des personnages les plus forts de cette
saison c'est vrai qu'un a plein qui se
disait on perd on perd thomas cc c'est
compliqué regarder son élimination temps
apprenez votre sac aller récupérer votre
flambeau et venez me rejoindre
[Musique]
thomas les aventuriers de la tribu
réunis qui ont décidé de vous éliminer
et leur sentence est irrévocable
sept jours j'ai fait une belle porte
ichou merci beaucoup thomas
merci au revoir bon moi aussi c'est
vraiment thomas thomas ya une question
que vous me posez moyens il ya une
rumeur persistante surtout à enfin
depuis la fin du tournage
qu'est ce qui se passe avec mini myriam
la prof d'anglais ne font rien selon
closer tu aurais même quitter ta petite
amie pour elle oui selon closer non pas
du tout
non non je suis pour un couple avec
madame c'est juste une pote à moi
d'accord je suis content avec monsieur
comme je suis pote avec janis oui c'est
pourtant je chante pas avec mathieu sur
banksy est ce que tu veux je vais quand
même enquêté et une amie ennemie
d'accord très bien non mais voilà parce
que c'est vrai que tout le monde a dit
chelios travail et il y en a dit je lui
ai demandé mais voilà comme ça moi je
suis là voilà je le sais maintenant oui
c'est parce que les relations avec
vincent se sont assagis basket avec nous
il ya quelques mois maintenant 20 ans on
n'a pas de relation il n'y a pas de ma
pression je vais batailler mois pour moi
il fait sa vie je fais la mienne
il n'y a pas de haine contre lui avant
au début de l'aventuré on était ami un
parent s de brest c'est mon ami mais
après bon ben voilà il
il a su vers un mondial c'était mon ami
tu sais comment ça s'est terminé par une
langue non justement
pas pour longtemps
[Rires]
koh lanta est trop dangereux et ya loïc
qui a perdu 15 kilos brice 13.5 d'orient
11 kg alexandre à 10 kilos lola 9 kg ha
tu sais comme j'aime qua non mais ouais
non mais ça rigolait vous dites oui je
fais jamais ce genre à bouffer des verts
il se faire chier d'actifs l aventure
ouais moi j'ai kiffé ce que vous
gagnerez du tout celui qui gagne ou pas
koh lanta gagnent 0 0
non jure bon mais quand même pas un
petit défraiement rien du tout prête
après on est on est de un mois et demi à
tahiti ouais mais alors voilà aussi à
dire un jour j'irai à tahiti et il m'a
payée mais sans rigoler quoi vous êtes
un mois de mai à tahiti et vous n'êtes
pas payé pendant un mois et demi bon
après on est payé semaine par semaine un
atelier on est salarié bravade est très
bon oui on est salarié de ces de combien
c'est un peu plus que le smic
d'accord blessé au marcel par semaine au
smic mensuel
et donc c'est au prorata par semaine
chaque semaine son rêve son nez d'accord
va traîner ça et ça je le savais pas on
va voir ce qu'on pense les
téléspectateurs à ce que koh lanta trop
dangereux oui à 18% nou na 80%